well this winner was showing off her
history-making grammy backstage
taylor swift i want to thank joe
who is the first person that i play
every single song that i write
the first female to win album of the
year three times thanks boyfriend of
four years joe alwyn
then shouted out a famous family i want
to thank james inez and betty
and their parents who are the second and
third people that i play every new song
that i write
yeah that would be blake lively and ryan
reynolds
backstage swift was swearing and
freaking out celebrating with a beer hug
from birthday girl este from haim who
might be after my job
i also feel like i work for et now if
you ever need a co-host
entertainment tonight anytime you want
i'm right here
your girl taylor also has a great
performance yes i know is there a chance
that y'all can go on the road
again we're ready taylor your people
call me i'm we're ready to go ready
here like any time we're here
[Music]
taylor laughing and talking with ex
harry styles eight years after splitting
and writing two breakup songs about him
a source tells e.t taylor and harry have
been
cordial for a while now and that's swift
happily naughty while giving harry a
standing o
when the brit won his first ever grammy
beating her
thank yep you
was censored but et's learned he said
all of these songs are bleeping massive
oh hello
backstage he didn't make up for not
thanking girlfriend olivia wilde
who was back in london and posted this
nod to his hit watermelon sugar
but harry did mingle with lizzo and gave
a fist bump and a hug to his competition